[Music]
welcome to a video on codetech tutorials
my name is matt and i'm going to be
talking today about my game engine that
i've been
working on for quite a while now
somewhat in my spare time and not
seriously this is my
little thing to hack on so don't take it
too seriously don't expect it to be
the best in the world or anything like
that is something that's
evolving all the time but this year in
2021 i do have plans to make this
actually usable to make games so i'm
just going to be talking about where
it's at what the plans are and what i've
been doing
with it recently so if you like code and
game engines and stuff you will probably
find this interesting
and i talk about this kind of stuff and
technology in general
on this channel a lot so consider
subscribing if you want to see more from
me and more of my shenanigans i also
just give random talks sometimes that
some people seem to like
so hop in let's let's go for a code ride
alright so one of the things you'll
notice about this repo and it is here at
this url i'll leave a link down below in
case you want to check it out further
one of the things about it is well the
branches are kind of a mess and that's
something i
intend on straightening up uh pretty
soon
about as soon as i can but uh so there's
a master branch and the master is
pretty broken uh it works sure
it's it's good enough but it's not
really i kind of branched off from that
and rather
making a completely new repo or anything
i just made some branches that are very
different so the master branch is like
legacy right now it will go away at some
point
uh there's no real official release but
i did make some tags
or stamps i thought would be neat to
look back
on but
[Music]
well about a month ago i decided i was
just going to
do a whole new thing so right now the
way this is there's like
you see this main aaa engine branch and
that is like the library and all these
other
things are just sub projects so these
are just standard c
plus plus projects these other ones here
and they all link to this main engine
this main library so i decided to make a
branch called
isolation fitting because of you know
the whole pandemic thing right
but also the point of isolation here is
to isolate the library and not have a
bunch of sub projects and with the
project and i think the way to make it
simple as possible
is just cut all the what do you call it
the chaff
i don't know so there's just the library
and that's it
it has source and includes simple enough
and you'll find all sorts of stuff for a
game engine in here
and i took it even a step further and i
went ahead and made isolation 2
where basically i once again branched
off
and decided to start adding unit tests
so
the only thing it has in the project now
is the main library that you link to
and unit tests you can run to make sure
everything is actually functioning with
the library
and that is still in progress it's got a
lot of ways to go i also kind of redid
the readme
and as you can see it is this simple to
run once you get going and that's one of
the
points of it just make it super simple
you just include the header
and then you just call run because this
is a
state-based library sort of like uh
i guess sort of like a lot of libraries
are where you have like
a state of things and you run it and you
can change the state and it changes how
things work there's a lot more to it
than that but basically you can
do your own design flow before you hit
this run
and make it do whatever you want you can
make it load models sounds do logic with
models and sounds
and uh stuff like that
so now i'm just gonna pop open visual
studio here and we're just gonna
open the project yeah i'll show at the
end how to actually include
this library and your own project and
get your own project going
using just this library that's what i've
done here with this project called
quell the panic i was gonna make like a
little survival game
it's just uh you know it's kind of a
test
platform in a way to see how usable the
library is to make a game
and that's something i want to do every
once in a while just to kind of get a
feel from where it's at from a different
perspective
one thing that's really hard about
working on an entire game engine by
yourself is
there's so much to do and sometimes when
you're down in one area like sometimes
i'll get down into like
i don't know something about textures
and i'll just be there for days and i
kind of forget
about like all the other stuff that
needs done and what might not be working
properly and stuff like that
so trying to like just stepping back
and like taking it from a new
perspective of
of the freshest mind i can like ignoring
all the internal work i'm doing and
saying hey if i'm a user coming from the
outside just trying to use this engine
what roadblocks am i going to run into
and that's kind of the point of all
these other little projects
i think there's another one here that
actually works a little better called
classic
asteroids and this user
there it is so i made a little asteroids
game out of the library this is kind of
out of the old version of the library
but it does all function and i talked
about this in the previous ones but
it was pretty cool you know there's
music and sound effects and everything
here
so this was kind of a uh
early state of testing things out now
a lot of improvements have been made
since then and this won't work on the
current isolation branch because a lot
of changes need made but it's something
i might update
but if you do clone this cast classic
asteroids
it does automatically link to the right
versions
of everything so it should just run you
should be able to just open it with
visual studio and run it
okay so let's uh let's take a look at
what this project looks like and then
i'm going to show you
how to use it and hopefully you're
enjoying this just to vlog
i don't know what people are going to
get out of this but
um i just think it's interesting and i
like having conversations about this
stuff so
all right so over on the right side
you'll see the main project right here
and it's got a bunch of files
uh some of them are even collapsed but
i'm going to collapse that for a moment
and you'll see the unit tests here now
i don't know if this is uh one of the
one of the pitfalls about unit tests and
one thing i found kind of annoying
that i'm just going to mention because
maybe there's something i'm missing
about this
but i noticed that i couldn't step
through the debugger when running
unit tests which i'm kind of doing these
unit tests in a weird way because i'm
like launching windows
uh like actual physical windows and
stuff so for example let me just show
you these
texts real quick we've got
a set of six tests here and uh
we can like go through them all because
they basically just start up the engine
and check that it runs correctly
so like the first one just doesn't
launch shuts down
after a second so it's just a quick run
the second one does the same thing but
it changed it does a
soft reset and then it changes the
background color somewhere there it is
and then it runs
so just some sample run cases to make
sure it actually runs properly and then
we start getting into more things this
one loads the model and moves the camera
uh this one tests that the key bindings
are working with asdw
and i can move around a little bit the
next one here
it's a first person test i think now
that's wazda next one's a first person
test
that just tests some first person
movement setup so you can actually look
around with your mouse
move around with asdw like you know like
any normal first person game
so just making sure that functionality
is all good to go
so another thing about these tests is
it's something that's a programmer could
look at and be like ah here's how you do
that so you could literally copy all
this code
and get your first person started and
then edit from there for example
so it's just kind of a nice way to see
how to actually use the
the engine too and then the last one we
have is custom shader test
i've been messing with shaders they
still need a lot of work but one of the
things i did is i made some of the core
ones like the one that just
shows the diff which is the colors of
your textures that one's internal
so you can just use it if you're not
doing lights and you just want to make
sure like
some bass stuff works you can just use
the diff shader
and i also there's i also added in
some support for loading your own
shaders so you can load your own shaders
or you can use the internal ones
but there's a lot of this is messy right
now like
the variables have to be named certain
things there's a lot of work to be done
on that front while it kind of works
right now it's not
really in an ideal place for true uh
development and
reverse tile developments like you have
to stick with a very certain pattern of
doing things
right now with these shaders until they
become more improved so that's one of
the big things i need to work on and
that i've been toying with and learning
about
because i do want to give some tutorials
on shaders 2 for my opengl
tutorial that i've been working on so
one of the things i do here is i like to
really
test things thoroughly and make sure i
understand them on this engine before i
go give a tutorial
so yeah that's the last one there is the
custom shader test and i'll just hit a
quick run we'll just run
all the tests here so you can see it fly
through all of these
and kind of see what it looks like now
this isn't super impressive but
it also doesn't test everything in the
engine there's no sound test yet i still
need to make those
i need a skybox test because there is a
skybox that works
so there's like windows black window
with different colors zooming out of the
model
there's a move with wazta and after you
get each of those it goes on to the next
test
it's loading it looks like and here's
the first person one
uh there's just a few basic things to
tell you stuff
but you can see i put some uh
negative x and the z to so you can kind
of tell what direction you're looking
so that way you can see it works mouse
movement works uh
moving keys work and i think i have a
full screen function here too
to make sure it resizes the viewport
correctly and that seems to be okay
and we're just gonna get out of this now
there we go and the last one is
kind of broken so you'll see it's tried
to load a model but it
didn't load the textures there is some
bug going on right now where
if you previously loaded the texture and
then you
cleared it out and then you load the
same thing later for some reason it
glitches out
i'm still working on fixing that so
there's a lot of little things like that
and when i'm diving in
and fixing those i'm often learning a
lot about
things i didn't realize before
okay so now you might be asking if you
know you might want to play around with
this and see what i got going on
and see if there's anything to learn
from it how do you actually use it and
include in your
own project well it's pretty easy to do
and i'm just gonna show you that by
starting up a new project and walking
through the steps okay so let's go about
making a
new project and then link it in now what
you gotta do is just
i'm gonna be using visual studio here so
just open visual studio
and create a new project so we'll create
a new project here
and we'll just do an empty project
using the c plus plus workflow of course
so you gotta have that installed that's
assumed you name it whatever you want
i'm just gonna name it asdf for a second
because
it doesn't matter i'm just gonna delete
this after this video anyway but i just
wanted to show you an example if you're
making a new project how to
link this particular library and it's
the same way you link any soft module
really but uh i don't think many people
know this to be honest
it's pretty somewhat obscure i think all
right
well so now we have this there's no code
there's nothing
nothing here yet it's just an empty
project and if we want to add
to this basically all you want to do is
go to your
solution explorer here however you get
to that and just add a root file
you can probably do this second i'm just
going to leave it named source.cpp
that's going to be fine and i just kind
of want to put the base case in here so
that we know when it's working
obviously it's not going to find it yet
it doesn't understand what this is
but if we put our root case in here when
it is working we'll at least know
so turn actually i'm going to use the
namespace
namespace
so when this all works we know we have
it all linked up correctly
so the next thing we're going to do is
just basically what we got to do is add
the sub module
to this project and you have to do that
through the terminal there's no way
that i know of any way i'll stop my head
to do this through visual studio
so what i usually do is i go to i
usually use fork
i use the program forks i'm i'm gonna
launch fork
and there it is fork i don't know about
fork
it's just forked.dev it's just a program
to help with git
and what i'm gonna do is go file
its new repository
and i'm going to point to that project i
just made which is this asdf right here
so i'm going to double click that
hit select and it'll kind of initialize
it
and we're not going to commit any of
this yet but what we can do now
now that we have it selected we should
we can just go to the console up here
and you can manually go to your console
we do this too you don't have to use
fork
and it gives us the little get client
here
so uh all we got to do is go get sub
module
uh add then the path
to the sub module hold on a second let
me look this up make sure i'm doing
straight
okay so there is some documentation if
you just do a google search you'll find
the site all about git sub modules you
can learn a lot also if you just type in
the wrong commands it does try to help
yourself
so basically what we want to do is get
sub module we're going to do add
then we're going to specify a branch
because i don't want to be using that
master branch i want to be using that
isolation 2 branch
ultimately we just need this branch and
path so
we're going to go get sub-modular add
dash b
and
and then we need the uh the repo
yo i went to it on github on the master
branch but it doesn't matter
we're gonna specify that one anyway so
we just need this root link here
so copied that and i'm going to go back
to
here and just paste that in
uh pasting there we go
and then the last thing here you can
specify a folder you want this to be in
otherwise it's just going to be in its
own folder so i'm going to just name
this you know usually i
make a folder called sub modules or
modules or something like that
i'm just going to call this one aaa
engine in all caps
but you can name it whatever you want or
just not use that at all and it'll just
clone as well when you
see this but it's nice to kind of have
your sub models in a folder sometimes
that way you can
keep them a little cleaner now it's
going to clone all this stuff and do its
thing here
it's going to take just a minute so now
what we can do is we can go back into
visual studio
back to our solution explorer and
go up here and just go add
existing project because we've cloned it
it exists
and we want to go well into our folder
there's the folder we
cloned it into and when we go into the
engine and there's the project right
there
now you'll see it's up here
so this uh a engine is only made for
64-bit so you do have to switch to
64-bit
uh you might as well just go to
configuration manager and just
edit and remove the 32 or
whatever which is fine
and you can do the same for each of
these little projects you'll see that
this one already hasn't removed but the
one you just made
won't uh it's not that big of a deal you
just have to have them set right
so we'll just go ahead and hit close
but now you see we're on 64. it still
doesn't see this stuff because we just
need to link it so we go to this asdf
project right click on it add reference
reference to aaa engine and now this
include path
uh sure we could we could make it
between double
quotes and really long but i like to
just go to the preferences here
and change this like i did earlier
because this makes it so that someone
else clones it
it will just work solution dir
and the name of the folder and then
a engine i think there we go
now we'll be able to easily include just
like so that should
clear up after it figures out there we
go now when we just hit play it's going
to build everything this is going to
take a minute
as you can see it's building the entire
engine there
it's going to build our final source on
this little project
and that's going to be it that's that's
all you that's all you got to do to
get this going now there's a little more
to know once you get into this like
how to update the sub module and update
just the branch if you have questions
you're welcome to ask
there we go okay and it's running
there's a base run
so now we could start actually like you
know building a game in the source file
over here and it would show
so i i believe this works a lot like ray
live i haven't used ray live but
um i noticed it and realized that i'm
basically rebuilding ray live which
isn't the intention i just you know
doing my own thing basically but uh if
you want a fully functioning working
one ray live seems like the way to go
but yeah i started this way before i had
any idea what ray live was
so i'm not trying to copyright life i
just realized that uh one day that hey
this kind of already exists i'm just
but uh i'm doing a separate thing i'm
definitely not trying to do what really
is doing although you can make games
with great life too
all right but anyway if you need to
update the sound module or do special
stuff with it you can find documentation
here about how to do it
i usually just use fork go to the
console
and i believe we go like git
all update well i think i've covered
enough in this video it's been pretty
long thank you all for watching
i hope your uh your coding adventures
are going great
and i want to do a little special shout
out to my patreons i'll put something up
here and uh just thank you guys so much
it really helps me keep going
when uh people sign up over there you
know i know life hasn't been
easy for a lot of people these last few
years but uh let's hang in there guys
let's make 2021 great and we'll see you
in the next episode
peace out
[Music]
you